doesn't look like anything to me
[Music]
Westworld is back Season 2 episode 1
there will be spoilers short versions
for the free version is I like it see a
lot of possibilities of where it can go
so yeah I'm gonna be talking spoilers
getting into this thing so I did my
video yesterday on my feelings on season
1 overall and I'm liking how this picks
up I while I appreciate that they're
using sort of the staggered timelines as
a narrative device again it makes me a
little bit nervous this time I
appreciate that they it doesn't look
like they're trying to do it as a rug
pull this time which it was to a certain
extent in the first season because
especially you didn't realize that the
conversations with Dolores and who we
later learn was Arnold it looked like it
was Bernard were actually happening in
the in the distant past and also finding
out that William was you know another
timeline to a character that were you
seeing much older you know that would
that was a reveal so I'm hoping they're
certainly not going to try and pull that
trick again that's part of why I'm a
little bit nervous of the fact they're
messing with time here like opening with
Bernard being you know waking up you
know on the shore and then a whole bunch
of it being being spent in a flashback
especially dealing with him and Tessa
Thompson whose character I don't think I
mentioned in the first season overview
she was pretty good and that she didn't
stand out to me overly at the time since
I've seen throw Ragnarok and she killed
it as Valkyrie I sort of have a
heightened awareness of her now funny
how that happens sometimes and she and
she is interesting even in the first
season she was interesting in terms of
you know sort of a little bit of
corporate and corporate espionage going
on but it looks like we've got basically
a full military response to what's
happening with the hosts on this island
which I mean it's hard to argue with
that with that response
given what Dolores appears to be doing
now the horse does seem to also be
killing some of the hosts which is
curious I will be interested to see how
the show justifies that my read on it
right now is that she's weeding out ones
who she doesn't think will be able to
break their programming who are going to
be too stuck in one way of in the inn
they're programmed way of thinking that
may or may not turn out to be the case
that's my own read on it I'm really
gonna be curious to see what happens
with Teddy upland by James Marsden who's
another character I'm pretty sure I
forgot to talk about I am my season 1
overview now the thing with Ted now
Teddy didn't really do much first season
I don't think ultimately however I think
james marsden was really well cast in
the part I think he just exudes a
certain sort of classic hero vibe which
makes him a really good fit for the the
white hat cowboy it was a good match of
actor to material because as soon as he
strolls in looking like that you you
immediately get a it's the marshal good
guy we get it and I noticed like when
he's with Dolores Dolores is gunning
people down she is hanging them she is
pretty brutal which is nice and I like I
mentioned last time that I I find
murderous Dolores way more interesting
than yo meek Doris and as much as I
enjoyed the transition I I want her in
this new place and she seems to be
pretty firmly there but I did notice
teddy Teddy's not shooting at anybody
he's with her he's not trying to stop
her but he's not taking part and I will
be interested to see I I'm gonna I'm
calling it now that she's gonna end up
shooting him or he's gonna make the call
that he has to shoot her they're what
they're gonna one of them is gonna kill
the other I'm making that call right now
so I'm gonna be curious to see how that
plays out
other than that I've been ed Harris
William in this in this world he he's
been waiting for this for real stakes
life and death and you can see that
there is a new sort of sense of urgency
about him and he's you know he's lacking
the the sheer confidence he had before
because he can actually die now but he's
also clearly invigorated by that like he
whether or not he would have wanted all
these other people to die I kind of get
the feeling he might not have cared
either way but if I didn't actively want
that but he wanted this scenario he
really wanted it and the interaction
with him and the and the kids sort of
speaking for Robert was a nice bit of I
felt kind of closure on on Robert Ford's
legacy and also I there's something
great about that line that the kid says
them you know this game is for you
because that was that was a Williams big
frustration because he'd been following
the maze and the maze was never meant
for him the maze was for Dolores and the
maze because it was a journey of
self-discovery and of you know coming to
a sense of of realization of herself was
a journey that he couldn't take you know
he was already self-aware he was already
sentient so the journey of the maze was
one of achieving sentience which he
already has so and the fact that that
that game was never for him was clearly
a point of frustration for him but
here's a game this is for you let's see
if you lived through it and I as as
brutal as he was last time I have to
wonder if he's gonna be like even more
off the leash now I'm really really
gonna be intrigued here I and
I have to wonder to a certain extent if
we even have a hero this season like
first season you know Teddy you felt
something before I mean I I would say
was probably Dolores because you know up
until the last episode you didn't know
that her journey was going to end with
her becoming very bloodthirsty so he or
she's she's definitely sort of seen as a
probably does not shy shy away from how
brutal she is so if there's gonna be a
hero the season I think we're probably
looking at Bernard and/or Maeve because
she's back and doing the stuff that
she's so awesome at working the
situation getting people to do what she
wants them to do through coercion
through blackmail through threats and
and I'm AI all boy she's so much fun
she's a lot of fun to watch and we get
the first bit of nudity we get here is
not only of a man but is of a human
character as opposed to a host so that
was kind of nice because I mentioned two
of my issues with the exploitive nature
of the show last time and I I don't want
to see the show overdo it but I don't
know there's something about having it
be a human this time and also having it
be a man and be like okay it's your turn
you feel dehumanized you be treated as
an object see how you like it so that
that worked well I'm I just feel like
this this was a really strong opening
reestablishing all the characters
reestablishing how just turned on its
head this whole situation has made
everything and I'm really gonna be
curious to continue to see how they're
trying to contain it what it is they
hope to get out of it you know how
things continue to build what Maeve's
going for
William finds out what Dolores has
planned because she does really seem
like somebody who has a plan but I'm not
sure what it is
and yeah I'm excited to see what else we
get because this is this is a strong
start
so episode 1 of season 2 of Westworld
what were your thoughts on it assuming
you saw it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do like support me a patreon follow me
on Twitter or listen to my podcast links
for all that stuff and more is down in
the description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]